cabriole entre chats et autres
arabesques les habitants de
mantes-la-jolie ont pu découvrir
gratuitement dans le square brieuc stèle
bourgeois le ballet giselle l'opération
opéra d'été en partenariat avec le
département et l'opéra national de paris
permet à neuf communes des yvelines de
pouvoir proposer à ses administrés des
opéras et des ballets classiques
de quoi ramener la culture au coeur des
villes il faut aussi que la culture
aille au plus près des habitants
il ya une demande à mantes sur l'opéra
sur la musique sur un certain nombre de
choses et donc dès qu'on peut le faire
en plein air dans un cadre sympa il faut
pas s'en priver
et l'année dernière ça avait très bien
marché je suis sûr que ce sera le show
ce soir et ils étaient plus d'une
centaine à découvrir le ballet ce soir
là
dans le public beaucoup de familles j'ai
juste vu qu'il y avait de la danse
classique donc mais qui font de la danse
classique je me suis dit ça pourrait
peut-être les intéressés jasper l'année
dernière j'étais venu enfin jamais vu
cendrillon là aujourd'hui
c'était très très bien donc je me suis
dit bon bien cette année je vais y aller
aussi pour d'autres c'est une première
il n'avait jamais vu d'opéra ou de balai
avant cité est la première fois que je
venais voir un opéra de quoi ouais je me
suis dit pourquoi pas venir parce que
j'avais jamais vu donc probable
découvrir quelque chose de nouveau c'est
une très bonne initiative de permettre
aux gens de découvrir qu'ils connaissent
pas ou guère d a priori comme moi de ne
pas y aller à l'opéra
une façon de découvrir les plus tard
samedis 12 et 19 septembre d'autres
opéras et ballets sont prévus dans
différentes villes du département comme
à jouy en josas où sera diffusée la
traviata ou encore aux clayes-sous-bois
avec le lac des cygnes
[Musique]